hi in this video I would discuss two
crucial but simplistic concepts in
immunology so I'll describe the
difference between antigen and immunogen
and the relation between them so
antigens are simply stated as substances
which specifically bind to antibodies in
brackets the b-cell receptor or the
t-cell receptor so definitely these
small progeny sheis or glycoprotein
easiest molecule molecules could bind to
t-cell receptor or b-cell receptor and
there is a criteria they would be de
marketed as antigens now these antigens
could be found from specific pathogens
such as bacteria and viruses or itself
inside the cell the endogenous proteins
could sometime also serve as self
antigens and we would come to know that
what is the function of these self
antigens now body produce self on
antigens just to say just to convey this
message to the immune system that our
our body is protected and our body is
fine and don't hurt us so it's like a
protective flag so there are
surveillance cells such as NK cells they
always roam here and there and look for
whether the cell is projecting the self
antigens or not so the self antigen
gives a signal to disengage so that is
why self antigens are equally important
as the antigens which are coming
externally from pathogens now the there
are another term which is known as
immunogen so as immunogen immunogen can
bind to t-cell receptor or b cell
receptor and not only they can bind to
the t-cell b-cell receptor they can also
mount an immune response so simply the
immunogen's are kind of antigens which
are not on which not only bind to the
b-cell and t-cell receptor but also
mount an immune response so that is a
different difference between immunogen
and antigen
so we can say that an immunogen is
necessarily to be an antigen but all
antigens are not immunogen many antigens
which are a small molecular size known
as hapten they are not able to create an
immune response by themselves and they
are going to only create an immune
response when they are conjugated with
several other sort of several other
carrier molecules so immuno gene is
molecular Li more complex than an
antigen so immunogenicity of any antigen
depends upon its molecular size
complexity and also the chemical
composition and heterogeneity of them
and definitely its foreignness like the
source where it is coming from that
because self antigens don't sort of
produce an immune response against its
own system that is how this terms are
explained if you liked this video give
it a big thumbs up and don't forget to
Like share and subscribe thank you